good evening and welcome to that car
race today
the last angry King joins that guy as
they look at a subject that they know
very much about being a good loser sit
back and enjoy Young America films
presents the chocolate Eagle production
oh they're already rated this film it's
2 stars the John Kerry story Centron
bringing you silhouettes of happier
families and yours and now I'm sure
you're all interested in the sults of
our class selection not even a little
the votes have all been counted and the
new president of our senior class is ray
Medford allow me to teleport into place
hey I appreciate this on you've given me
take your top off and I only hope I can
do as well say that everybody met for
sure is a swell guy I'll say just look
at all the things he's done I'm talking
and you can rest assured I'll do my best
to be a good president of the finest
class Lincoln High has ever had
oh not including the class of 37 we're
not fit to take their chops
congratulations ray thanks a lot big
what you crazy gonna ventilate oh that's
all right if you need any help on
special committees or anything just give
me a call here well big yes
there goes what I call a good loser he's
lost everything he's ever competed at
what a pro
okay I gotta go okay security security
oh and then Edward kissed Bella and
bullshit at the start of his senior year
we all knew rain Medford as an excellent
student and a swell fellow and a gentle
kisser Oh wine took a lot out of him I'm
the debate coach here at Lincoln High
and I regarded Ray as a fine speaker my
line okay he had won the extemporaneous
speaking contest Emperor Aeneas what
district and state meets for the past
two years checking his line again good
ray was confident sometimes even a
little cocky because ray knew how to win
he cheated frequently all right yes you
come over here for a minute please
okay miss Marie that bring that sweet
ass with you ray yeah I'd like to have
you meet Marilyn Jackson hi Marilyn
hello perhaps you remember Marilyn from
the tryouts last week ray no sir she was
the woman that you look familiar
we're going to use Marilyn and
extemporaneous except Irenaeus is that
sort of break her in to take your place
next year
Oh had me worried there for a minute
coach I thought maybe I'd lost my place
on a team oh no I thought what I'd like
to have yeah yeah shut up lady is to
help coach Marilyn this year I don't
have time to give her all the help she
needs
I'll do it back into hell that means
well well go to it kids and you need any
help
ray let me know okay thanks miss Marie
so Edward carrot bill it's at the top of
the mountain done have you had much
experience in public speaking Maryland
no I have it this is just my first time
but I've heard you the last two years
when you want to state championship for
it and you were just grand I was just
lucky but not what we can do to help you
Nora
now first Todd Cutright start over each
speaker my ass ray worked hard with
Marilyn and he worked Marilyn Hart find
suitable material for practice he
pointed out the flaws in her delivery
tunnel is the brass suggested ways for
her to him
proved and most important Rey was
patient and understanding Oh RAM so
science of slow to catch on I met mr.
Murray won't even take me along for the
trip oh he'll take you along for it nice
of you to help me this way right let's
try to give ray and Marilyn both worked
hard at the job of getting Marilyn ready
for competition even though it was a
lost cause and as time went by Marilyn
improved steadily it stinks with ray
always helping always encouraging always
urging her to do better the better got
David to water then came the big day of
the district tournament at Lincoln High
yeah this tournaments just kind of like
old times you wouldn't ray well I don't
know looks like pretty rough competition
this year how about you Marilyn you read
nothing des Carrodus all I am did you
just turn it olive oil speaking that's
okay you just do what I told you you'll
come out all right all right coach but I
doubt if I get very far in such
high-level competition is this you eight
and see just remember if you're nervous
I am imagining you and your underwear
our team had done remarkably well in the
morning and feelings were running high
when the extemporaneous what is what
does it mean when his turn came ray as
always was sure of himself and spoke in
the crisp smooth manner that always
brought approving smiles to the faces of
the judges we approve ray was carrying
the banner of Lincoln High to another
championship
Marilyn was the last speaker at first
she had a bad case of stage fright and
seemed a little shy
the more she talked the more confident
she became listen up you bastards
Marilyn was doing all right dance of it
dance and the judges well Marilyn had
impressed them two were impressed after
their conference in which they weighed
the merits of the contestants the judges
announced the results third place in the
extemporaneous speaking folks we don't
have the energy to make another
extemporaneous joke just use your
imaginations second place winner is mr.
ray Medford not better luck next time
there wait what
and now for the obvious twist first
place in the extemporaneous speaking
contest goes to miss Mount Jackson
tyke as it was her stage fright and
nervous flaws that won them over
thanks thanks this is a great day for
men feeling sorry for women
excuse me I'm denying you three times
gosh ray I'm sorry I don't know why they
picked me but I want you to know that I
realized that it was your house that
made it possible for me to win yeah
Marilyn had won fair and square
she saw the resentment and raised eyes
I'm sure she would rather have lost now
she she left with him as for Ray well
losing was a new experience for him but
when he'd become very familiar with and
I wasn't quite sure just how it would
affect him all right so I lost to a girl
off my back well as a champ
dad I didn't Lincoln doesn't have much
competition this year but I will the
winner winner pressure pressure pressure
winner winner winner pressure pressure
pressure
jesus H to win a third dad I didn't win
huh I have no son
yeah what I lost my son you've won the
district title for the last two years
great at least it wasn't to a woman
Victor J Maryland Jackson won the girl
you've been cooking well Marilyn Jackson
yeah yeah well what do you know about
that
son I'm demoting you to daughter whoa
ray how'd it go he lost oh well well
hath lose some time you've had your
share of winning he lost to Marilyn
Jackson pussy she's a little girl Ray's
been getting ready to take his place
looks to me like she got ready a little
too soon son
well that fixed everything
Frank you shouldn't tease him about it
yeah it's all right Mary
he knows I was only kidding him okay
then oh there's got to lose once in a
while he seemed to be taking it pretty
hard
oh that doesn't mean a thing Ray's
always been a good winner and you'll be
a good loser too I hope
yeah back to the Kaiser isn't did you
see that look of rage basement she got
that from me let's go burn our bras this
is the watershed moment I girl hey
Marilyn you really surprised it why now
that your district amp your first year
wha who knows you might be able to go
ahead and win a state title for three
years like Ray tried to do you could
achieve where he failed well why not you
betrayed didn't you we didn't figure you
could do that either
hey Marilyn how did Ray take it we slept
on coach or hailed a cab fine again but
look you know I couldn't have won if Ray
hadn't helped me Harry comes home
walking on Sarge
hey ray how about coaching me for the
exhibition meet next week don't do it
ray you just can't trust these women to
learn all your dumb like puberty really
gave up on him - Marilyn dead chance the
chump in 10 easy lessons why don't you
all shut up
he likes praises when he wins getting a
little kitten when he loses and well
we're supposed to shut up
oh I don't think you should tease him
about it he's won lots of time maybe
that being a winner
he's never learned how to be a good
loser well I never expected ready to be
that kind of a curio then Ray's worse
than Hitler
ray I'm sorry I got you into all this
I'll bet you are really I didn't have a
fun side day I'd win you'll always be
the best as far as I'm concerned a baby
fresh sighs oh man that was business of
being so afraid poor helpless little
girl didn't know a thing about speeding
oh what a laugh ray I did not Oh what
for you boys she gave up pretty quick
Marilyn I'm sorry
you do know she's not the scene anymore
ray will you come here man I played what
what we're just sitting there the whole
time I'd like to talk to you about plans
for the state contest next
right there mr. Murray I'm not going to
be on the team anymore do you have a
reason did you not see the big fight he
just had ray you don't like being
second-best very well do you
I mean that since you didn't win first
place for once you've decided that if
you can't be best you won't be anything
I don't think I know how much winning
the contest meant to you ray and I know
that you feel Marilyn has in some way
betrayed you and I know that you've been
taking quite a bit of ribbing from some
of your friends living back then that
brutal hazy but we're a team ray and as
a team we'll win or lose together
Marilyn's first and your second place
gave us the tournament I can't stress
enough how little your win hell ray
largely due to your speech and your work
with Marilyn ray think this thing over
get on okay
think how dick reacted after you beat
him in the student council election be a
stickler huh stop looking at your lives
don't you have two cards think Ray you
can win a lot of respect and inner
strength by becoming a good loser just
think if you work at it you could not
only be a good loser you could be a
great loser perhaps the greatest loser
the world has ever known
well it's up to Ray now he can still
change his attitude I can get the gun to
the bell tolling a good winner make it
hard to be a good loser well by
definition yes would ray have been a
better loser if his family al friends
hadn't kidded him about his loss that's
the way they all became the central
Bunch well ray ever be able to be our
graceful loser loser yes graceful no how
would you have acted if you had been
rain what do you think
I think facial tattoos of question marks
are going out of style
it says release